今まではこの 何でしたっけ
四念処経というヴィパッサナー瞑想について
お釈迦様おっしゃったいろいろ瞑想方法とか瞑想のやり方とかまとめている経典の説明をしてきました
それからこの瞑想っていうのは順番がありまして
まず体について気づくということで始まるんですね
そこで体という言葉を取っちゃうと
いろいろありまして 体の動きとかね
そういうものがありまして
その瞑想をずっとこの最初のところで説明しました
で それから体の中身見るとかね
体を不浄として三十二に分けてみるとか
あるいは体物体として地水火風に分けて観察するとか
それから体ただの死体だと
心がなければ単なる死体であるということで死体として見るとかね
その場合はだいたいまた瞑想のやり方いくつかありまして
自分のことを観察する
他人のことを観察する
それから自分と他人と五分五分で交互に観察する
それからその真理として一般的に観察し
一般的なものとして観察する
この口で出てないでください
で そうやっても観察するの四つあります
また繰り返しますけど
自分のことを観察する
他人のことで観察する
それから自分のことと他人のことで両方で観察する
それからもう一般的な真理として観察するということ
それは経典では内の体を観察する
外の体を観察する 内と外の国と観察するという風に書いてあるんですね
その四つの観察をする
それで瞑想次第にそれまた変わっちゃうんですね
例えば呼吸だったら 呼吸瞑想だったらもう当たり前で自分の呼吸観察する内から始まるのは当たり前なんですね
それから 地水火風の瞑想だったら
内から始めたって外のものはこれは硬いものだから地ですよ
これはもうつなげてるものだから
これは水 幻想ですよと見たって
それは構いません 外から見ても構いません
それからはっきりと言えば
この死体の瞑想の場合は
やっぱり外から入れないと
もう自分が死体になったところで瞑想することはできませんから
その場合は外の観察から始まるんですね
死体見つけたら 死んだ死んだ人が見たら
あ この人はもう死んでいて
こんなこの様だと 私もそのようになるんだと
それで自分のことを観察する
自分もこの情になるんだと
自分にもそれ映してみるんですね
自分も死んだような感じで
それからだからって大変ということじゃなくて
世の中のみんなそんなもんだよというふうに一般論として観察するという
それ体の瞑想なんです
たくさんあります それから次に我々が説明したのは
この感覚の瞑想ですね
感覚というのは三つしかないんですね
苦しみの感覚 楽しみの感覚と一般的な感覚という三つなんですね
それでそれはだいたい自分から始まるんですね
自分の体でこの苦しみが生まれると
これは痛みとかね 楽しみが生まれていくと
これは楽しい感覚と楽しい感覚と
ごく普通の感覚はごく普通に感じているんだということで
だから感じているんだ
あるいは痛みですよ 今楽しいですよとかね
そういう 3つに分けて観察する
それから外の世界を見たっても
どんな動物 どんな生命見たっても
苦しみから避けることと楽しみを追っていることと
そういうこと見えますから
他の生命に対してもあるのはこの感覚三つですよということで観察すると
それでそれが終わりまして
それから心の観察に行くんですね
心の観察っていうのは自分の心の状況を見ることですね
だから心というのは見えやすい
見にくいんだから 大体わかる範囲でやるんですね
大体十何何枚でしたっけ
十何 いくつかに分けてましたけど
うん で 例えば自分の心見たら
なんとなく欲があるんじゃないかなと思ったら
今欲がある心だと その欲が消えちゃったないところで
今は欲がない心と怒りがあるとわかるんですね
今起こってるんだと 今
今の心が怒りの心だと
怒りが消えちゃったら
今の心は怒りがない心だと
で 無知が出てきたら あまり訳も分からない状態になって
混乱状態になってくる
今はもう無知の心だと
それ消えちゃったら心しっかりすると今は無知が消えたところだと
そうやって心の状況から心のことを判断する
それから心がなんだか小さくなってやる気がなくなっちゃって
今心が小さくなってるんだと
それから心がなんとなくもうやる気があるんだけど
しっかりしない あれもやりたい
これもやりたいって なんとなくもう大きくなってる状態になってくる
心はまあその状態になってるんだとか
それから また触ったら
塗ったらとか そうやってサマーディとアサマーディとか心の状況があります
そのその時の自分の気持ちですね
心の働きっていうのは
そうやって心を見てみると
そうするともうかなり瞑想はだいたい十の方に行っちゃうと
もうほとんど修行っていうのは終わり
もう終わるぐらいのもうしっかりした瞑想法なんです
この最後までやらなくちゃいけないってことじゃないんです
一般的には この適当に体が見てくる
見ると それに必要なものは感覚も見えてしまう
すぐにそれに必要になるぐらい心も見えてしまいますから
それに必要なぐらい方も見えてしまうんです
ですから このわざわざと苦労しなくたって
瞑想を始めたら適当な量で
心中身法のほうに瞑想っていうのは自動的に回っちゃうんです
自動的に回るんですね
だからあまり特別な苦労しなくてもいいんですね
例えば膨らみ縮みなんか感じていると
まあ体はあなたもう結構ですよと
これから感覚見なさいってことになってくると
痛みやらいろんなこと見えてくるんですね
それで膨らみ縮み見るところじゃなくて
痛みとか もうそういう感覚を見ていて
それ見ていると それ十分だからと
それでいろんな雑念やら妄想が出てくるでしょうに
そこをラベリングしちゃうと
もう心のことを見ているんですよ
そこをずっとまとめてミスまとめて経験から見ると
なんかちらちらと法の方も見えてるんです
だから まあ心っていうのは落ち着きがないもんですよとかね
すぐ変わるもんですよとかね
で 体もその場でその場で変わるもんですよとか
いくらかいくらか この方の方ももうとっくにわかってるんだから
この心中身法の段階っていうのは
私は身の方 体の瞑想合格してから十の方に行くんだということではありません
ですから いつ私は心の瞑想をするんですか？とか
それを聞く必要もないんです
ただ この基本的な瞑想のやり方を決めてる
決まってるんだから その基本的なやり方だけ守ってみれば
自分の能力次第で自動的に心中身法の方にずっと回って回って回って回っていくんですね
だから いくらか一部をやってしまったら
このやらなかった部分が自動的に出ていくて
そこを実践してみれば
そこをいくらか平らになったら
それまたやらなかった部分がまた出てきて
それで一旦平らになったところで
また芯から始めなくちゃいけないんですね
また体を観察すると またもう十と身と
また法の方でまた一回りをして
またまとめてくるんですね
そこでもう完全に煩悩なくなるまで
なんも繰り返して繰り返して繰り返してやらなくちゃいけないんですね
こちらでやるのはそうではなくて
この学問的に 知識的に
論理的に綺麗に分けて
お釈迦様は説明しているところですね
今日残っているのは一応それまとめ
今までの話で まあそれぐらい簡単にまとめるんだったら
あの掛かった時間は何なのかと
笑ってくれる それは私の
腕の見せたと  こう こうご期待でございます
今日は法の観察っていうことで
カ
タンチャパナ・ビククヴェ・ビクク・ダンメー・ス・ダンマ・アヌパッシー・ヴィーラティ・ダ・ビククヴェ・ビクク・ダンメー・ス・ダンマ・アヌパッシー・ヴィーラティ・パンチャ・ス・ニーヴァルネー・ス
カタンチャパナ・ビククヴェ・ビクク・ダンメー・ス・ダンマ・アヌパッシー・ヴィーラティ・パンチャ・ス・ニーヴァルネー・ス
イダ・ビククヴェ・ビクク・サンタン・ワ・アッジャッタン・カマーッチャンダン・アッティメー・アッジャッタン・カマーッチャン・ドーティ・パジャナティ
アサンタン・ワ・アッジャッタン・カマーッチャンダン・ナッティメー・アッジャッタン・カマーッチャン・ドーティ・パジャナティ
ヤター・チャ・アヌッパンナッサ・カマーッチャン・ダッサ・ウッパドー・ホーティ・タンチャ・パジャナティ
ヤター・チャ・ウッパンナッサ・カマーッチャン・ダッサ・パハナ・ン・ホーティ・タンチャ・パジャナティ
ヤター・チャ・パヒーナッサ・カマーッチャン・ダッサ・アヌッパドー・ホーティ・タンチャ・パジャナティ
それで一部そこで止まりまして
この二重と書いているところですね
十ページの同じテキストを持っているならば
この同じテキストを持っているならば
そちらに二重書いているところ十ページ目にダンマアヌパッサナーと書いてます
で 説明に入る前に このダンマアヌパッサナー
法を観察するということで
だからこの法って何なのかという問題が出てくるんですね
こちらでお釈迦様は法はこういうものですよと定義はしてないんです
定義してないんだからといって
これ欠けてるかというと欠けてるわけじゃないんです
それ必要じゃないんだから定義してないんです
それはそれからの説明でわかると思いますね
だから この一般的なインドの世界で
インド言語学の世界ではダンマっていうのは
まあ一般的に使う言葉なんです
サンスクリット語だったらダルマと言うんですね
で それは一般的に使う言葉で使うあの面積といえばものすごい幅広いんですね
だからこれはもう翻訳はできません
そのインド的な哲学文化以外はもう理解もできない
英語でも言葉はありません
あるんだったらすぐ見つかりますからね
あの だいたいラテン語
ギリシア語で一応基本的なことは見つかるはずなんですね
同じ言語だから ドイツ語でもまあいろいろ苦労するんですけどね
ないみたいですね だからダンマはダンマで
ダルマはダルマで 他の似ている言葉はない
まあ漢字で法というか入れてますけど
だいたい似てない それでもなんとなく影響を受けちゃって
法という漢字を一応似ている方に使ってるとこ見えます
だから一般的なインド世界から見ればダンマって何でしょうかと
その使ってるその脈略において
すぐもう理解しちゃうんですね
だから我々にとってはもう当たり前で
とても簡単な言葉なんです
全然もう苦労しない もう日常茶飯事で使う
子供たちも使う とても軽々く
あまりにも一般的な言葉なんです
とても軽々く使うだけで
だけど決してこの誤って使ったりとか
これわからないんですよということを決して起こらないんですね
それぐらいこのもうそのその文化の生活にも厳密に定着している言葉なんですね
ですから この言葉勉強することは
他の文化の人にとっては大変なことにはなりますけどね
だから私にしても これぐらいの意味ですよというのはちょっと言いにくいんですね
だから どんなどんな背景で
どんなどんなことで使うかっていう例で言うしか方法ないんですね
だからどんな意味でしょうかね
ダンマっていうのは まあいくらで頑張って思い出して言いますけど
例えば世の中に 当たり前で普通に起こる出来事
それはもう避けられない
どうしてもそういうことになる
例えば昼が出たらすぐに夜になる
不思議でも何でもないんです
今もう昼間だから どんどんどんどん夜になる
夜になったらどんどん昼になる
それからもう秋になったらそれでもう紅葉があるし
冬になったら寒いし もう夏になったら暑いとかね
で もう春になったら花が咲くとかね
そういうふうなこの決まりがダルマなんです
その場合は何なのかね
ダルマっていうのは で
例えば自然法則ダルマですって言ったらちょっとおかしいんですね
自然法則ダルマ 自然法則イコールダルマではなくて
まあそういう風にも当たり前のことで
不思議なことでも何でもなく
もう当たり前に起こる出来事
また誰にもそれは変化させようというのは無理
そういうことだからダンマと呼ぶんですね
夜になることをどう頑張っても止まることはできませんだから
そういうことをダルマと呼ぶんですね
それはある姿でしょ それからあるべき姿をダルマというんです
だからあるべき姿というのは大体はない姿でしょ
そうすると道徳的な価値観になっちゃうんですね
いわゆる希望的観察でもダルマと言うんですね
実際の状況を判断して理解する法則にもダルマという
それから希望的な状況を判断して言うことにもダルマという
例えば真理を語るべきですよと
人は嘘をついてはいけないという
そんなことはダルマですよと
ダルマですと言ったら
みんなもう当たり前で
もうダルマだからということで
もう 例えば我々の日常生活する中で
人にあなたに何のダルマもないねと言うんですよ
そういうのも行儀が悪いと
いう意味なんです 常識がないと
いい加減やという意味なんです
だからやっぱり人であるならば
行儀よくちゃんとした性格があって
しっかり生きていけ いけなくちゃいけない
いけなくちゃいけないのに
そこをだらしなくなっちゃったら
我々は何もたくさんの言葉を使わないと
もう何もダルマがないねと言うんですね
それから道徳をまるっきり侵してしまって
世の中の行くべき行くべき道をね
から全く外れた人が 例えば犯罪をしたり
いろんな悪いことをしたりする人については
もうダルマを壊した人と言うんですね
アダルマの人だと だからその場合はそこで使っちゃうんですね
そこでアダルマの人だからといって
その人には昼は夜で 夜は昼というわけじゃないんです
そこで道徳的な観察なんですね
道徳的というか希望的でということでね
そこで人が何を守るべきかと
だから ダルマを守るべきだと言うんで
その時は それどういう意味ですかね
で それもいくらか道徳的かもしれませんね
それから人が何に従うべきかというと
我々にはすごい簡単に答えが出ます
ダルマに従うべきですよと
だから 守るものと従うものと言えば位置が違うんですね
守るものっていうのは自分の中にあるもので
従うべきものといえば
自分より外にある尊いものなんですね
どちらにも同じ言葉を使うんですね
人がダルマを守るべきと
先生 内なるダルマ 外なるダルマと解釈してもいいですか？それとも違う
そういう言い方は合ってない
だからこれはまあ だからご自分たちの日本の方々が
まあ私は人間として何を守るべきかねとか
自分で聞いてみれば その出てくる内容がインド文化だったらダルマというんです
で 必ずしも日本人に聞けば出てこないと思いますよ
ヨーロッパ人に聞いたっても
じゃああなたは人間として何を守って生きる生きるべきかと聞いたら
もうわからないでしょうね
家族を守るか 自分の体を守るか
どちらかとわからなくなっちゃうでしょうに
ということは そういう文化で
そういう考え方がないということなんです
日本人なら多分道っていうと思います
だから道という言葉は
このラオツやらインドから来た言葉だから
でもそれはもう日本文化の中入ってるから
入ってるからね で 道といえば守るものじゃないんです
それは歩む歩むところだから
従う法則の方なんです
ん？ 実践する 道は実践する
実践するものだから この従うものなんですね
だから人は何に従うべきか
どのように生きるべきかと言えば
日本人は道というかもしれません
でも何を守るべきかと
尊いものとして 宝物として
自分の命みたいに感じる
何が失ってもこれだけは守りますよと
と言えばないんです ないから
はっきり私もそれは言いにくいんだけど
そのその人に聞かないとね
インド文化系だったらもう何のことなくわかってないかもしれませんだけど
もうダルマという言葉出すんですね
これはダルマですよと
自然の知恵みたいなもの
知りませんよ 私に聞いたって
自分の問題だから 自分で聞いてみればダルマがあるかないかと
お釈迦様の法則っていうのがダルマって読んできたんですけど
それとも違う  うん 今言ってるのはブッダの意味というより
一般的なこの言葉と あの言葉の意味なんですね
いわゆる辞書を引いたらどんな意味が出てくるかということなんですね
だから辞書を引いたらかなり苦労するんですよ
大量にいろんな意味書いてるんですね
何ページも渡って だからこの
一応大雑把で理解してください
例えば皆様はどんな解釈でもいいんですよ
例えば もうある人が私は心の清らかさ守るべきですよと思ってますよと
ある人はまあやっぱり他人に迷惑かけないで
まあ自分なりにこそこそと頑張るって
それを守るべきですよと
ある人は 人はやっぱり正直でなければいけませんと
というふうにいろんなことを言うかもしれませんね
だからそこは人が個人的に守るものはそれぞれ違うんですね
だから私ははっきり答えいたくないんですね
だから その人に その人によって
自分にとっては一番大事に守るべきものは何でしょうかと聞いてみたら
それはインドだったらダルマと言うんですね
そのダルマは何ですか？と聞いたら
掃除きであることをやら
ものすごくもう頑張ることであることをやらね
あるいはもうもう猶予あるかもしれません
日本では法的な言葉よりも法律っていう風に結びつけてね
なんとかの法を破るとかって
そういう風な解釈しててね
あんまりこのダルマに対しての認識とか表現は少ないようですよね
なんとなく法律 なんとなく法とかになっちゃってる
それからいきます  そういう風に
この我々には決して乗り越えられない
大事に守るべきことを真理としてもダルマと呼ぶんですね
それから従うべきもの
それから自分としてこれから頑張って守ることも
またもうダルマと呼ぶ
で もう簡単に善悪判断の世界でも
もうダルマという言葉があります
それから この我々に生き方を教えてくれる人々の話
例えばお釈迦様の話 イエス様の話
それは人間に何か普通と違うことを言ってるんですね
学校の先生の数学の授業と違って
イエス様の話は違うことを言ってるんですね
イエスの話にしてたっていうのは
それは一生人間はもう聞いて
もうやらなくちゃいけないことを言ってるんで
お釈迦様の話もそういう話でしょうし
そうやってこの宗教家というかね
我々の精神に まあ精神を育てるために生き方教えている教えそのものにもダルマと呼ぶんですね
だから聖書っていうのはダルマなんですよ
ダルマテキストなんですね
インド文学的には解釈すると
だからヒンディー語でダルマという言葉使ってますよ
聖書に あれはキリスト・ダルマなんです
ヒンディー語だったら
だからスリランカどうでもキリスト教について我々はキリスト・ダルマと言うんです
ブッダの教えはブッダ・ダルマで
キリストの教えは イエスの教えはキリスト・ダルマで
だからお寺に来てお坊さんの話を聞くことも
説法を聞いてるんですよ
で 教会に行って牧師さんの話を聞くと
それまた説法を聞いてるんです
それでまた何のことなく使うんです
神父さんの牧師さんの話は説法ではありませんということじゃないんです
それは説法を聞いてる
こちらも説法を聞いてると
そうやってこの あの その意味ははっきりしてますね
だからこの宗教的な立場であの教えると
だからその場合は宗教という特別な色付けなくても
人にちゃんとした生き方を教えることはダルマと言うんですね
それまた一つの意味 もう一つの意味っていうのは
この世の中のどういうものにもあるこの法則
それもダルマなんですね
例えばこの科学で何を発見するかと
特に物理学で何を発見するかというと
この物質の法則を発見しているでしょ
物質はどのように動いて
どのように反応しているんですかと
うん だからカメラのレンズなんかはどのようにできてるんですか？というと
光の法則を勉強して 光っていうのはいろんなものに触れると
こういう風に屈折するんだとかね
こういうところでまとめるんだ
どういうところではもうもう広げるんだとか
いろいろありまして そこを工夫してカメラのレンズを作ってるでしょうに
望遠鏡を作ってるでしょうに
顕微鏡を作ってるでしょう
だから顕微鏡はダーマではありません
望遠鏡もダーマではありません
でもダーマがあったんだから
それできちゃったんですね
この顕微鏡 望遠鏡を作った人には
ダーマには全然立ち触ることはできません
何もできません 例えば光は屈折するんだっていう
それはやめますと やめ
やめさせてできません
それはどのように使うかって
使って品物を作るかっていうことは別な話で
だから物理学者は自然法則を壊してないんです
壊すことは不可能なんです
で その 例えば車を作って作ったんだから
地球の引力を壊しちゃったんですかね
壊してないんです で 地球の引力あることを十分理解して
それをよく理解して このダーマをね
地球引力についてのダーマを理解して車作っただけ
飛行機作っただけ 壊す
壊すことはできない では宇宙船だったらやっぱり引力壊して
壊してないんです 壊せません
それは十分計算して G
のパワーをね それでまあ自分である道具を作ってるだけのこと
だからその道具を作るために
その人々が必ずも知らなくちゃいけないことは
このダーマなんですね
その場合は引力のダーマ
そうやってこの法則にもダーマと言うんですね
だから仏教から言うと
因果法則 因縁論はダーマなんです
だからお釈迦様はダーマを教えてるんだと
何を教えてるんですか？と
ダーマと言ったら いきなり因果法則を言うんです
嘘を言うなということではなくて
因果法則を言うんです
だから仏教イコール因果法則になっているんです
それもダーマの一つの訳
定義なんですね それからこのこちらの方おっしゃったこと
あの法律 法律っていうのは
人間が人間のために 人間の平和のために定めるものなんですね
一旦定めちゃったら もう守れと
壊すなと 文句言う権利何もない
たとえ人間が法律を作ったっても
一旦作ったらもう守るしか道がないんですよ
抜け道がない 抜け道で抜けちゃったらズルいことするんだと
そこで悪いんだったら
また抜け道も塞いじゃうんですよ
そういうことで法律にもダーマと言うんです
だから裁判官 審判か裁判官っていうのは
もうダーマの ダーマを判断する人なんですね
だから昔のサンスクリット語
パーリ語だったら 審判官に使う言葉はそういう言葉なんですね
ダーママッハとかね いろいろ言葉がありまして
このアショーカ王さんももうダーママートラという言葉を使って
それはもうダーマミニスターですね
ダーマ大臣 ダーマ大臣って何？何なのかと
まあインド人にとってはよくわかります
ダーマ大臣 何なのかと
法務大臣 法律の関係ね
法務大臣ということなんです
そこで法律作ったり 政治をやったりする場合は
まあ今まで政治システムないんだ
憲法がないんだ だから何でもいいんだから作れということでもないでしょ
法律ないんだから もうなんとか一時法律作ろうと
例えば人間に政治が全くなくても
法律が全くなくても どこかで何か道が決まってるんですね
いわゆる政治家の理想みたいなもの
法律の理想みたいなものはあるんです
あるんだけど それは何なのか誰も知りません
はっきりと でも我々感覚としては知ってますでしょ
だからこの法律もダーマなんですけど
この法律を作らせる この誰もはっきりわからない
この理想のようなもの
それもダーマなんです
だから政治家も王様もダーマに従って生活しなくちゃいけないんだと
厳密に言うんですね 王様であるならば
ダーマを第一に大事に守らなくちゃいけないんだと
その場合はダーマっていうのは法律でもないんです
王様にとっては自分が法律作るんだからね
もう勝手に帰ればいいんだから
嫌だったら 例えば独裁的な政治家であったら
やりたい放題のことを
人を殺したりいろんなことをやってるでしょう
もう一般的な常識の法律は守ってないんですね
国王だったら王様だからね
もういろんな一般国民にはいろいろ法律を作るんだけど
自分では別に守る必要はない
だからそうやってこの免責という免許
何て言いますか 法律からまあ自分はもう法律に問われないということもあるでしょうし
でもそれでも何かに何かの決まりに守らなくてはならないんですね
それはヨーロッパの政治学では簡単に説明していますけど
まあ変ですけどね そこで向こうでヨーロッパの政治学の初めでは
政府っていうのは 王っていうのは神様が決めたものだと
だから王様やら政治システムというのは神様が決めたもので
政治家が王様が神様との約束で国民を支配すればよろしいと
そうすると神様の約束だから
そこは文章になってないんですね
だからどこかで自分がやっぱりちょっと真面目に
いい加減でなく生活活動しなくちゃいけないという風に自分を戒める
なんかなんとなくそういう働きは世の中にはありまして
それにもダンマと言うんです
まあそれ そういう風にたくさんダンマがあります
それで仏教になってくると
さらにさらにダンマのことが変わってしまって
お釈迦様おっしゃったこの生き方
戒律 道徳もダンマであり
それは当たり前の定義で
それから物事を厳密に分析して
本当にあるものに戻って
ところで いわゆる幻想のレベルに戻ったところで
これ以上分析できないんだと
その幻想のレベルに戻ったところのものにもダンマと言うんですね
例えば生命とかなんとかじゃなくて
仏教でいうのは物体があって心があると
ナーマがあってルーパがあると
物質があって心の働きがあると
ですから心はダンマであって
物質であるルーパはダンマなんですね
そこで心っていうのは一つしかないんだから一つですよ
それでも心の中に怒りがあったり
欲があったり 無知が生まれたら
いろいろ感情が生まれる
そういう感情もどれぐらい生まれるかと
すべての感情がもうたくさんあるんだけど
丁寧に分析してカテゴライズしたところで
仏教では見つかっているんですね
まあそれぐらいですよと
怒りがあると怒りの反対の慈しみが出てきたりする
欲が出てくると その反対にもう自分でもらうんじゃなくて
人にあげたくなる気持ちがなってくるし
まあ落ち込んだりする場合は
それ一つの感情で もう明るくなって行動したくなる感情もその反対にあるし
だからって何でも悪い感情といい感情というのは五分五分であるわけでもないんですね
だから悪い感情14があって
悪いいい言えない感情がこれもう
十三ですね  十三ぐらいありましたとかね
で それから良い感情は二十五種類あるんだというと
まあやっぱり五十二に全部もう感情分けてあって
だからそういうものには法と言うんですね
なんで法と言うんですか
それ以上はもうそれ以上分析できないんだと
だからそういうわけで困ったもんなんですね
ダンマっていうのは 法律もダルマなんです
そこで あのこちらで定義していないのは定義する必要ないんだから定義していないし
これからもうこれ実践の経典だから
実践する方法を教えているんだから
まあダルマの瞑想 ダルマのことをダルマを観察する人はどのように観察するべきかといったところで
まあ修行者にとって悟りを目指している人にとってはとても大事なダルマだけ
どうしても見ておかなきゃいけないダルマだけ教えているんですね
例えば地球の引力もダルマなんですけど
そこはどこまで勉強したって
もう何にもならないでしょうに
人はそのまんまでしょうに
瞬時に計算できるんだと
例えば十グラムの物体がもう百キロぐらい高いところに三分間で送るんだったら
どれぐらいエネルギーが必要で
それをGで計算すればすぐできますよ
でも我々にとっては結構時間かかるかもしれません
だけど 例えばある人がかなり数学は上手で
もう瞬時に言えるかもしれない
だからだから何ですかね
それもうGのエネルギーはよく理解して
いろんな形で飛行機作られるんだと
ただそれだけのことなんですね
ですから ダルマのことを観察しなさといったってもね
地球はどれぐらい大きいですかとかね
地球と月の間の距離はどれぐらいですかとか
毎日その距離はどれぐらい変わったりするんですかとかね
そんなものを計算したっても
全然心の問題に何の関係もない
でも科学者はものすごい厳密に
やっぱり月と地球の間では距離がもういろいろ変化するんだと
それで地球に地球 月にあの鏡を一つ置いておいて
これからこちらからレーザー光線を送って
また反射して戻るんだからね
その時間をね これ時間の差をね
計算しながら毎日やってるんです
それ膨大なバカでかいコンピューターで計算して計算して
まあこれぐらい差があるんだとかね
そこでどんな物体も光出してるんだから
この物体の中身を中身に中身に置いて反射する光が変わるんです
物体に光を与えた光が戻ってくる
戻ってくるんだけど 戻ってくる光がこの物体の中身においていくらか吸収しちゃう
そうすると この反射してくるエネルギーを明確に分けてみて
その物体はなんでできているんですかと計算するでしょ
あれはなんて言いますか
あれは 何グラフ うんと特別な言葉ありますね
これ星から遠い星の中出てくる光をこのあのなんかあの
ああ そうそうそう スペクトグラフと何とかっていう風に分けて
そこで青い色があったり
いろんな色があったり
いわゆるこの虹のように映っちゃうんですね
そこを見てみて あ こういう品物で来てるんだ
こういう品物で どういう品物で来てるんだと言うんですね
誰も言ってないでしょう
例えば火星だったら でも火星は何？どんなものできてるんだと
こちらデカそうなこと言ってるでしょうね
火星のところか１億年
1 光年前のもう四十光年前のとか
ところにあるあの星はこういうものできているんだとか言ってるんじゃないですか
どうやって言ってるんですかって
あの光の分析して言ってるんです
で じゃあこれ考えてみればすごい知恵のように見えますけどね
で 役に立たないんです
すごいことやってるなとは見えるんだけど
何の役にも立ちません
それでもって一向に我々食べるトマトが美味しくなったということはないんです
だからトマトに塩をかけたら美味しいですよと昔の人々が発見したものは役に立つでしょうに
役に立つでしょうに だからこの人間にそれがないんですね
だからどんな知識を得てよろしいか
どんな知識がくだらないかと
それもわかってないんですね
だからくだらない知識を得るとキリがないんですよ
なぜならば 知るものはいくらでもあるんだから
いくらあっても何の役にも立たない
役に立つ知識だけよと思ったら
もうこれで十分やっていうことでリミットがあるんですね
だから知識は仏教は否定してないんだけど
だから増やそうという変なことは言わない
例えばお金は否定してないんです
財産は 財産は必要で だから増やそうというあのひと言葉を言わないんです
あれはもう狂っちゃうところなんですね
世界の人間が 財産はもういいですよと
幸せになりますよと だから適量を得てくださいと
そこだけ仏教は違うところなんですね
人間はそこはやってない
ですから この法はたくさんありますけど
もうだからって全て知ってる必要なくて
自分の心を清らかにするために
解脱を得るために必要なところだけ
まあここで選んで言ってるんです
まあ最初に出てくるのはイダ・ビッカヴェ・ビックー・ダンメー・ス・ダンマ・ヌ・パッシー・ヴィーラティ・パンチャス・ニーワラネー・スという言葉
パンチャス・ニーワラネー・ス
パンチャ・ニーワラナ
ニーワラナっていうのは
ニーワラナというのは蓋という意味なんですね
まあ蓋なんですよ これは 5つあります
我々の心をあの覆っている蓋が 5つあります
そこで心は強くならないんです
明るくならないんです
ものすごい暗い黒い蓋が 5枚で押さえられてもあるんですね
それはまあ基本的な法で
基本的なダンマで どんな人の心も思い存分なぜ力・光・力が発揮しないかというと
この蓋でもう鍵をかけているんですね
もう鍵かけるというより
すごい蓋でもう押さえられているんですね
その蓋は 5つありますと
その心にそういうというのはダンマなんです
心にまたいろいろ法則があります
ダンマありますけど でもこれは一番大事な肝心なことなんですね
だからこれは先に知っておかなくちゃいけない
なぜ人に勉強できないかと
でもこの 5つでやられているんだからなんです
なぜ能力ないかと ですから
これを勉強しておかなくちゃいけないんですね
そこで瞑想したっても
自分の心はなぜこの次元を破って
この即次元を破って もう自由な次元を見つからないかというと
破るところがここでも薄いので
もう抑えられているんだから
それだったら先にその 5つを知るべきなんですね
だからこちらで言っているダンマは
必ずしも瞑想する人が観察するべきもの
であって これ観察しなきゃもう何の意味もない
進めません  1番目はイダビッケウェービックーサンタンワアジャッタンカーマッチャンダン
1番目はカーマッチャンダ
カーマッチャンダっていうのはこの五欲ですね
五欲を好むこと 五欲っていうのも体のことなんですね
目で見たい 耳で聞きたい
それしか世界がないんだと
楽しい世界はただ目で見て楽しむ
耳で聞いて楽しむ 鼻で嗅いで楽しむ
舌で味わって楽しむ 体で感覚を楽しむ
ああ これこれしか楽しむ世界がないんだと
いて そちらの奴隷になって
体の奴隷になっているんですね
だからもう進めないんですね
いくら頑張って目で見えるものしか追って探していけないんだから
耳で聞こえるものしか探していけないんだから
それはカーマッチャンダと言うんですね
それで瞑想する時でも
すごく瞑想嫌になっちゃう
早くこれやめて終わって
あのどこかに行きたいとかね
早くこれ終わってご飯食べたいとかね
違うことやりたくなるんですね
瞑想途中でも なぜ瞑想嫌になるかというと
もう体のことで それやって最高の生活だってそればっかりやったっていいんだけど
でも全然こう世の中でね
テレビを見ながらご飯食べながら
もうよく寝て よく遊ぶ生活では結局つまらないでしょうね
そればっかりやっちゃうと
ものすごい虚しくて つまらなくて
遊ぶだけの人生だったらすっごい嫌になっちゃうでしょうね
それなのに瞑想しましょうと言っちゃったら
もうやらないんです またあちら見ちゃう
だからそれものすごいバカバカしいんだけど
やっぱりなかなか人間にはそこを理解しないんです
だからカーマッチャンダが生まれたら
この五欲が生まれたら心に
これは蓋ですとですよと
あ 今自分の心にはカーマッチャンダがあるんだと
例えば早く瞑想をやめたいなとかね
これ早く終わったら このまああの必要な番組がありますから
それ見なくちゃいけないなとかね
これ早く終わったらすぐ行ってご飯食べなくちゃいけないとかね
あるいはもう何時に寝られるかなとかね
そういうふうなことを思い浮かんじゃうと
あ それはカーマッチャンダで瞑想を邪魔しているんですね
心は開けないようにしているんですね
だからどうせ答えがこういうこと
いつ瞑想終わるかということなんですね
そちらにあるのは だから心育てることは
もう早く早く早く終わりたいんだと
だからあの学校で子供たちに授業なんかやってると
子供たちは一番気になるのは時間なんですね
別にすごい時間守って行動するんじゃなくて
いつ終わるかと この授業は
それすごい気になるんです
ということは 授業は聞きたくないということになるでしょうに
そこでこのこういう風に我々の心を抑えられている
このカーマッチャンダ
五欲と欲蓋ですか というものがあります
それは心に働いて出しちゃうと
これはカーマッチャンダですと確認して認識する
だからサンタンワアジャッタンカーマッチャンダン
自分の心の中にカーマッチャンダがある時はアッティミアジャッタンカーマッチャンドーティパジャナティ
今私にカーマッチャンダがあるんだと理解する
アサンタンワアジャッタンカーマッチャンダン
カーマッチャンダがない時は
今はカーマッチャンダがないんだと
それをわかる時は瞑想はしたいなと
あるいはやめたいなと
見たくないんだ テレビ見たくない
それかわりに瞑想したいなと思っちゃうと
もうカーマッチャンダが働いてないんですね
今はカーマッチャンダがないと
そこで確認する ヤターチャアヌッパンナッサカーマッチャンダッサウッパドホウティタンチャパジャナティ
アヌッパンナッサカーマッチャンダっていうのは
この今までなかったんだけど
後から生まれたんだと
例えば気持ちよく瞑想を始めたんだけど
15分ぐらいになってくると
やっぱりこれ早くやめてご飯食べたいなと思ったりする時もあるでしょうに
やっぱり途中からで生まれる時あります
途中からカーマッチャンダが生まれたら
今からカーマッチャンダが生まれたんだと
それを確認する ヤターチャウッパンナッサカーマッチャンダッサパハナホウティタンチャパジャナティ
それから瞑想途中でこの五欲の五欲が欲蓋が生まれていて
もう後で消えちゃうと
とるという覚悟を決める
やっぱりそんなことやるんじゃなくて
瞑想している時間だからね
そんなバカなことを考えるんじゃなくて
やっぱり真面目に瞑想するんだという風に決めちゃったら
カーマ・チャンダが消えるでしょうね
生まれたってもね やっぱり瞑想はやめて遊んだ方がいいんではないかなという気持ちがあるんだけど
やっぱりそれはあかんと
覚悟を決めて瞑想するんだと決めちゃったらカーマ・チャンダが消えるでしょ
ですから あったカーマ・チャンダが消えた状態
あ 消えちゃったと そこで確認する
ヤタ パヒーナッサ カーマ・チャンダッサ アヌッタ アドーホーディ タンチャ パジャナーティ
もし消えたカーマ・チャンダがまた生まれてこないんだったら
それも理解すると だからそこら辺はまあ説明しちゃうと難しいですが
だから欲もいろいろあるでしょうに
例えば二十歳の人が瞑想している
そちらに八十歳の人は瞑想していると
八十歳の人であろうとも
もうカーマ・チャンダはあります
あまり長い時間座ると
私の体がもう壊れるかもしれませんとかね
腰が痛くなるかもしれません
だからもうちょっと体を伸ばして
ちょっと散歩でもした方が健康にいいんじゃないかという
そういうことを思ったりすると
それもカーマ・チャンダなんですね
体に対する欲だから そこでこの二十歳の人は瞑想すると
あの隣に座ってる人も結構かっこいいんだからねと思ったりするかもしれませんね
結構かっこいいと で 仲良くしても悪くはないんですよとかねと思ったり
それもカーマ・チャンダなんですね
でも八十歳の人にはそのカーマ・チャンダは生まれてこないんですね
二十歳の人はまだ結婚もしていないんだから
もう相手のことを気になったりする
そうすると二十歳の八十歳の人から見れば
そういう欲はもう消えちゃったんで
また生まれてこないカーマ・チャンダかもしれません
でも八十歳になっても結婚する人は世の中にいますけど
だからそれ全てもう絶対的ということに言えませんだけど
自分にとっては自分が分かってるんだからね
欲はあるんだけど この欲はもう二度と生まれてきませんと
もう消えちゃったんだと
こういうこういう欲はもうもう消えちゃったんだから
生まれてこないんだと
そういう風にこの一旦消えた欲がまた二度と生まれてこない時もあります
そうやってこの欲望の欲望のことを
我々欲のこと 体を大事に考えることが生まれるたびに
その観察していく それは一番目
心の問題の二番目はサンタンワ アッジャッタン ヴァーパダン アッティメ アッジャッタン ヴァーパドーティ パジャナーティ
文章は同じ似ていますからね
ヴァーパダンという言葉だけ勉強すればいいんですね
ヴァーパダンというのは怒りですね
嫌な気持ち 怒り と言っても
そこで瞑想中 嫌な気持ちが生まれたら
嫌な気持ちがあったら何一つ動くいかないでしょうね
何か真面目にやりたければ
嫌な気持ちではやれません
だから我々の能力を抑えている次の蓋は嫌という感覚なんですね
嫌だと思っちゃったらもう終わり
もう能力はなしと 成長できません
いやいや やりたくないんだと
できるわけないでしょうに
だから本を読んでる時ででも
もう嫌になったらもう終わり
もう読んだって意味がないんです
頭はもう成長しません
だから人がせっかく心育てようと思ったところで
さっと嫌な気持ちが生まれてきて
もう抑えちゃうんですね
だから我々の心の中で感情として嫌な感情が生まれちゃうと
まあこれはすごい蓋ですよと
心を抑えられてる蓋ですよと理解しなくちゃいけないんですね
それはビャーパーダという
嫌な気持ちもたくさんありまして
怒りも一つで 憎しみも一つで
もういろんな形で嫌な気持ちが出てくる
生まれたら あ 今は心に嫌な
嫌という気持ちがあるんだと確認する
そこ消えちゃったら 今心に嫌という気持ちがないんだと
蓋ですよと 心を抑えられてる蓋ですよと理解しなくちゃいけないんですね
それはビャーパーダという
嫌な気持ちもたくさんありまして
怒りも一つで 憎しみも一つで
もういろんな形で嫌な気持ちが出てくる
生まれたら あ 今は心に嫌な
嫌という気持ちがあるんだと確認する
そこ消えちゃったら 今心に嫌という気持ちがないんだと確認する
そこで嫌という気持ちはなかったんだけど
後から嫌味 嫌な気持ちが生まれてくると
あ 今生まれてきたんだと確認する
そこで生まれてきた嫌な気持ちが消えちゃったところで
あった嫌な気持ちが今消えちゃったんだと
前にあったんだけど もう今消えてるんだと
それから ある嫌な気持ちがもう一旦消えちゃったら
もう二度と出てこないということもありますね
そういう気持ちも まあこういう嫌な気持ちは私にとっては出てこないんだと
こうにも確認する で 確認の仕方もそうやって決まってます
次に三番目 サンタンワアジャッタンティーナミッダンアッティミアジャッタンティーナミッダンティパジャナーティ
ティーナミッド ティーナミッドっていうのは昏沈睡眠なんですね
体も心もだるくなる なんか鈍い状態で
重い状態で 咲いてない状態はティーナミッドというんですね
ティーナミッドがない時はすごく活性化してるんですね
体も心も もう回転してるんです
よくもう動いてるんですね
だからこの体もやっぱりよく自由に動いてますけど
ティーナミッド入っちゃうとなんとなく動き動きにくいというじゃあ動きたくないんですね
どこかじっといたくなっちゃうんですね
だからこの なんとなく暗いみたいなね
重いだるいような状態なんですね
いわゆる分かりやすく言うと
もう寝たいという気持ちなんですね
その だから昏沈睡眠 まあ咲いてない状態と
はっきりした睡眠 寝たいという気持ちが生まれてきたら
もう心の成長はそれでストップ
だから寝ることで何も得るものはないんです
でも時々時々昏沈睡眠が出てきて
もう成長全部妨げてしまっちゃうんですね
ですから このこれも観察しなくちゃいけない
人の能力を全く発揮できないように無駄にしているのは一つのこれは巨大なエネルギーで
これあるんだったらどうにもならない
もういくら頑張っても
ですから まず昏沈睡眠が生まれたら
あ 生まれたじゃなくて
ある場合は 今体の中で心の中で昏沈睡眠状態があるんだと確認する
それをなくなっちゃったらもうなくなったんだと確認する
そのテキストに言ってる通りに確認する
そこで昏沈睡眠はなかったんだけど
途中でおんちん睡眠が生まれてきてきたりする
それで あ 後で生まれてきたんだと
で そうやっても確認する
で 四番目は三番目アッジャタン・ウッダッチ・クックッチャン
ウッダッチ・クックッチャンっていうのは
これまた心は成長しない
あの鋭くならないすごい理由一つなんですね
ウッダッチャっていうのは混乱状態
落ち着きのない状態 例えば
まあいきなり私たちはすっごい大事な人々のいるところにいきなり連れて行っちゃったら
どうすればいいか分からなくなっちゃうんですね
まあ一応テレビで新聞で顔を見たことはあります
何を喋るかと よくテレビで見ますね
なんとか天皇陛下人々集めていろいろ時々やるでしょう
なんとかなんとかって言いながらそこで人を選んで呼ぶんだけど
だからまあそこで突然顔と顔を合わせるとこで何も喋れなくなっちゃうんですね
あれはもうこの状態なんですね
どうしようかと 例えば人間だからなど
まあお前に来ていただけますと大変ありがとうございます
もう何のことなく言えばいいんだからね
だからみんな行く前に喋る言葉も訓練して
そこであの宮内庁からも
じゃああなたと天皇陛下が喋りますからとね
あなたはこういう風に言いなさいとテキストくるんだからね
それは天皇陛下にもテキスト行くんです
で この人にはこういうこと
この人にはこういうこと
天皇陛下も一生懸命勉強して
で やるんです だから決まってますよ
テレビでも自由に喋るように見えますけど
そうじゃないんです 誰とどんな言葉かけるかっていうのは
全部このテキスト通りに
マニュアル通りに行くんです
そうでなきゃ二人ともこういう上皇状態に陥るだろうと
天皇陛下にしたっても
どんなに人ですかとわからない
そちらは普通の人間 例えばテレビでよく見る映画でよく見るタレントさん
女優さんなんかだったら
そちらにも好みあるでしょうね
その人を見たらなんとなく湧いてくるでしょうね
感情は あなたの映画すごく楽しかったとかね
なんとか言いたくなるでしょうね
あるいは何も言えなくなっちゃうとかね
ことはありますから やっぱり念のために前もって何を書いて
文字通りに動かそうと
まあですからまあそうなったらどうにもできなくなっちゃう
例えばこのいろいろ発表会なんかの場合でも
もう何も喋れなくなったりとかね
人の前に喋ることになっちゃったら
何喋ればいいかとかね
人々を集めたら言葉出てこなくなっちゃって
膝が震えるようになったりとかね
そういう状態はウッダッチャって同義体なんですね
上皇と言うんですけどね
うん 漢字がまあこれは人間使う漢字ではなかったという感じだ
激高する 西面にテーブル
西面に卓だよね テーブルの卓にコア
激高する こう火って書いてあげるっていう
思い出しました   一般的な言葉で緊張という言葉がありますね
上がっちゃうってこと？ 上がっちゃうっていうことね
まあ浮つき上がることやら緊張しちゃうこととかね
そういうことでもやっぱり能力が消えちゃうんですね
覚えたものも忘れるし
習ったものももうなかなかもう手が指が足が動かなくなっちゃうし
ということだから この進めたければね
成長したければ この上がること
緊張感っていうのはもう全部きれいさっぱり置いておかないとうまくいかないんですね
それは心はものすごく引っ張っちゃうんですね
後ろに で 緊張と一緒に書いてるのがこのクックッチャン
クックッチャンっていうのは後悔
だから情動 後悔 2つ一緒に書いてるんですね
似てるんです 例えばあまりにも上がってしまって
もう何もできないでしょうに
後悔するとも後悔するだけで仕事はしないんですね
試験にってやっぱり勉強しておけばよかったのにとかね
そうそう考えちゃうんですね
もうちょっと準備しておいた方がよかったのにとか
そうやってこのもう後悔しちゃうんですね
後悔しちゃうと もう勉強しなくたっても
それ見て何かできることあるかもしれませんよ
それをできなくなっちゃうんですね
ですから 瞑想中でもいろんな後悔が出てくる
やっぱりもっと早く始めた方が良かったとかね
若い時始めた方が その気持ちが入っちゃったらもう終わり
まあ体が今病気でもう大変苦痛だから
やっぱり元気な時始めた方が良かったのにとか思ったりするでしょ
それでももうやめた方がいいんです
もううまくいかないんです
だからそれも後悔なんですね
なんとかのどんな形であろうが
後悔が出てきたら 上高状態が出てきたら
上がった感覚が出てきちゃったら
もう心がそこでストップにしてしまっちゃう
この蓋で その重りで抑えられてしまっちゃうんですね
だからその状況が生まれたら
ある場合は 今はウッダッチャ
クックッチャがあるんだと
ウッダッチャがある場合はウッダッチャがある
今上がっている状態 今緊張状態があるんだと
今後悔状態になったと
今後悔しちゃったとかね
そうやってその状態は確認する
次にあるのはこのヴィチキッチャという 5番目
サンタンワ アッジャッタン ヴィチキッチャン アッティメ アッジャッタン ヴィチキッチャーティ パジャナーティ
ヴィチキッチャっていうのはまあ決まれないっていう状態なんですね
これあの分析しちゃうと
定められない 自分の頭の中でそうかなどうかな
どっちかなとか その状態なんですね
はっきりしない状態 いわゆる疑と書きますから
疑いという感じでね で
疑いという風に書くんだけど
この機能はもう何か疑ってるっていうことでもなく
まあ疑いも同じなんですけど
はっきり自分でも決められないんですね
迷うような  迷い 迷いっていう言葉でしょうね
迷い状態が心に入っちゃうと
それでも心は一触になっちゃうんですね
だからこの疑という疑いという言葉だけ使っちゃうと
そんなに悪いものでもないんですね
なんだかはいはいわかりました
もう信じますよというね
そんな生き方じゃないんです
物は疑ってかかっていかないと理解できませんだから
本当かなと 本当かなと疑ってかかる人が
証拠を見て 証拠があるんだからやっぱり本当ですと決めなきゃ迷いとは違うんですね
だからこの疑ってかかることは仏教でも認めてますから
何でも鵜呑みにするなっていうことはもう徹底的に言ってるんだから
智慧の世界だから だから智慧っていうのはやっぱり結局は疑いから始まるでしょうし
科学もそうでしょうしね
疑うことから始まりますから
それは別にどうってことない
その疑いは元気なものだからね
懐疑的になる  いえ 迷うことなんですね
心は弱いんですね 結局は
どっちかな？どっちにするかな？そうかな
そうではないかな 違うかなとか
なんとかとか  だからそれは私
皆様の経験から説明しちゃうと
あの まあ我流に瞑想する人々の話を聞くと聞くとで
ある人の話を聞いたんだけど
私は今 あの 何て言いますか
自分の感情をね 貪瞋痴に分けてちゃんと観察しているんだとね
まあ頑張ってくださいという気持ちで聞いてるんですね
どうせもうろくな結果にならない
偉そうなこと自分で で
あ そうですかと言って
あの わからない だから欲も怒りもわかるんだけど
この無知ということは
まあちょっとわからないとかね
で そうやってもういい加減で貪瞋痴に分けてみようと
このカッコつけてるんですね
話をかじったりして カッコつけない
カッコつけないで私が瞑想法を教えているんだから
その通りにやればいいし
説法は説法で置いておいて
俺は何回 1億回も言ってるんだけど
それでも我流にやるそうと頑張ってね
じゃあやってみてくださいとね
ということで 別に人は自由だから
それ以上私には言う権利はないしね
いくらなんでも首にロープをかけてやらせるということはできませんし
そんな必要もないしね
で ですから一応この道ですよとやり方を
それでもそれを聞かないで
自分の自己流でもうやったりして分けたりで
もうこれはわからないと
でも本当はこれ この誤解がないんだったら
例えば一応分析しようとしたら
その貪瞋痴とわからないでしょう
はっきりと これは貪で
これは怒りだよと わからないとわからないということは理解しないんですね
その能力ない あ やっぱり私が今の感情が貪瞋貪
貪りか怒りかもうわからないんだと
自分がわからないことをしっかり知ってる人には迷いはないんですね
あれ迷ってるんですね
どっちにしようかなと
そういう性格で いくら観察持って行ったっても
知恵が出てこないんです
だから観察は鋭くしっかりするべきなんですよ
だから痛みだったら迷わないでしょうね
痛みと殺念といったら迷いはないでしょうね
これは貪りであろうか
怒りであろうが どっちにもあるいは不貪不瞋であろうかとかね
またある人がそれを言うんですね
貪瞋痴には一応わかること
分析することはできますけど
この不貪不瞋不痴の方がわからないんだと
そこを教えたっても意味がないし
もうそういう風にやったっても意味がないし
そんなことをチャレンジしなさいと言ってるわけでもないし
でも相手のががあまりにも強くても希望がない場合は説明してあげますね
希望はないとこの人は
もうそれだったら不貪はこういうこと
不瞋は 不痴はこういうこと
もう痴はこういうことで観察するんだと
一応セット教えてあげます
見分け方が 本当はそれでは効き目がないんです
教えてもらってやっても
あれはもうただ気休め
だから気休めをしてはいけないんですね
こちらは正直に指導しなくちゃいけないんだからね
気休めはよくない いくら腹が立ってもはっきり言わなくちゃいけないんです
人に甘える世界じゃないんだからね
もう早くも脱出させなくちゃいけないんだから
だから人の気持ちなんか計算する余裕はないんです
暇もない 本人にもないんですよ
やってる本人に 私は年取ってるんだからってわけじゃなくて
誰にでも時間がないはずなんです
それでももうあまりも我が強くて
自己流にやりたいという
ここら辺 強いとわかったら
もうあまりに煩悩がね
強すぎて まあそれだったら
まあ一応問題にならないようにということでは
一応明確にこれこれこれですよと説明しますけど
そういうのはほとんど要りません
ちゃんと進めるはずなんです
お釈迦様はあれほどしっかりと
私はしっかり教えてるんだからやってみなさいよと
これは一方通行の道であっても間違いはありませんと
それぐらい言ってるんだからね
やればいいでしょうにね
まあとにかくそうやってこの迷いということが働いちゃっちゃうと
知恵が出てこないんですね
だから知恵っていうのはしっかりと迷いなく確認することで
だから私はこれ知ってる
これ知らないと その区別判断が必要なんですね
だからこの知る知らない
その区別判断能力ないことはこの疑なんですね
まあ例えば じゃあ人が死んじゃったら生まれ変わるかないかとかね
仏教で言ってるんではないかと
だから証拠を出してみなさいとか
いろいろ言ったりするでしょうに
それも疑ばっかしで 私には疑はないんです
私に聞けば 私のことははっきり決まってあって
経典にはそういう風にありますと
それだけで十分な答えなんです
じゃあ証拠を出せと言っても
私の責任じゃないんだからね
それは私ははっきり知ってますよ
Aさんが死んでBさんで生まれて生まれたんですよっていう証拠を出すという
これは大変な仕事で できっこはないでしょうしね
だからそこら辺では証拠はない
それをはっきりしてるんですね
証拠ないってことは間違ってるって意味じゃないんだ
証拠は今のうちはないっていうことだけのことで
で でも気持ちを整理したければ
やっぱり経典でお釈迦様がそうやっておっしゃっているんだから
別にお釈迦様人を騙して何のとこもないんだから
お釈迦様にはね まあだったらまああるんじゃないかなと
でもそれは瞑想の邪魔には何もならないです
あってもなくたっても
だからそこら辺はもうちゃんと複雑で
迷いっていうのはもうすごくいい言葉で
この疑の場合はね 心は迷いがないようにしなくちゃいけない
迷いがないってことは
すべて知ってるわけってことではありません
私に迷いがない すべて知ってるんだから
そんな話じゃないんです
我々心に迷いという機能がないということで
だからこれだったら知ってると
これだったらダメと わかりませんと
例えば料理の場合は料理できますよと
で じゃあそれでもやっぱり煮物だったらもうできますよと
任せてください 天ぷらはちょっとごめんと
これはちょっとできませんと
というぐらいのことなんです
だから何ができて何ができないことをしっかり知っていると
迷いがないでしょうね
あるいはこれは今はできないんだけど
やってみればできそうだなと
それも迷いがない状態なんですね
だから迷いがなければ心がうまくいくんですね
ですから 我々の能力を抑えられている 5番目の蓋は
その迷いなんですね それも迷いがあると
あ これ今は迷いがあると
今はないとか確認していくんですね
だからこのそういうのはどんな人間にもその愚害があります
私が今更悪口言ったんだからといってね
もうない人が見つかりません
誰にでもあります でも
人々っていうのはこのいろんなレベルで生活しているでしょうね
すごい成功して まあまあ成功してとか
まるっきり成功はないとかね
あるいは失敗だけばっかしとかね
いろんなレベルで我々は社会の中で生きてるでしょうに
そのレベルはどこで決めるかと
例えばみんな努力しているでしょうね
学校に行ってみんな同じく頑張るでしょうに
気持ちとしては勉強したいでしょうね
それでも結果はバラバラでしょう
そこはこの愚害がどのように働いているかという
愚害が薄ければ薄いほどじりじりと成長してしまう
そこである時は愚害がなくて元気で勉強するんだけど
ある時はいきなり愚害にやられちゃってやめることもあるでしょうに
そういうことだから まああることはありますね
で 生まれたらすぐそれ確認しておく
あ 今はこれやるんだと
今は消えちゃったんだと
ヴィパッサナーの基本的な方法っていうのは
そういうのを全て計算した上で言ってるものなんですね
それにケチをつけたりして
我流に解釈したりして
瞑想法はね もう何の意味もないんですね
他の方法と組み合わせたりとかね
まあヨーガと組み合わせたりとか
もう何とかの宗派の教えと組み合わせたりとかね
なんで組み合わせ それ自体屁理屈でしょうね
そちらが良ければ その人はそこで満足するでしょうに
そこで満足してないということは
こちらに来たというその時点で
向こうの方法で満足してないということでしょうに
向こうの方法で満足しているんだったら
こちらには勉強するために来るんじゃなくて攻撃するために来るでしょ
あんた方は間違ってるんだ
私は正しい方を見つかってるんだという風に攻撃に来るはずなんですね
それだったら私の態度も違いますけどね
勉強しにやってみるために来たっていうことは
そちらの方向で方法で満足してないってこと
それなのにきれいに組み合わせると
そこで同じ結果 だから走れない人がものすごく走れる人を丸っきり走れない人と体を結んじゃったらもう走れないんです
結局は まあそういろいろありますから
やっぱり最初からもうそういうことはちゃんと注意して
それからこの心の働きは全部理解して
それからもう悟るってことはどういうものかと
またもうそれもしっかり理解して
それで人に方法を教えてるんでしょうし
人がわからないというのは当たり前でわからないんだからね
その世界はね だから言ってる通りにやってみなさいっていうことしか言えないんですね
それでもいい加減にいろんなことをやっちゃうと
はい どうもそこは悪いと
あなたのことはもう心配しないと
ということになっちゃいます
それだけのことで またもう一つ
だから世の中の人々は能力開発
いろんなことにすごい力入れてるでしょうに
人間の天才的な能力 みんな持ってるんだと
もう脳の細胞の中にももう知らされてる
何て言いますか 知らされてる
いろいろ知らされてないって言うんですけども
たくさんのあれやるわ
これやるんでいろいろ言うでしょうね
でも誰もなんでそれ発揮できないかと分かってますかね
世の中で能力開発を通してはものすごい分権になるでしょう
学問分野一つですからね
いろんな会社にしたって
もう社員の能力をできるだけ開発することにずいぶん力入れてる
ずいぶんセミナーやらお金かけてお金かけてやってるでしょうに
心理学の世界にしたって
たくさんテキストやらあるでしょうに
一人も見つかってない
なぜ心が成長しないかと
どこに抑えられてるかと
見つかるわけでもない
体が能力開発をしたいんだけど
体に対する執着はそのまんまですから
いくら研究してもそのまんまなんです
あのリスが檻の中で走ってる
ぐるぐる回るあれやるでしょ
俺の中でもずっと走ってるでしょうに
これ 10キロぐらい走ってるんだけど
1箇所なんですね いるところ
そのまんまなんですね
いくら上登ったってあれ回りますから
いるところはいる位置が同じなんです
例えば回るものは止まってもらえば
一応リスには一回り動きますけどね
あれ回るんだから リスはこうやって歩くだけで自分の位置が同じでしょ
だから人間の研究っていうのはそんなもんなんです
能力開発の研究 同じ位置だけなんですね
だからいろいろ実験とか見ると
本当に笑っちゃうほどなんですね
この超能力の実験とかね
このいろんなことをやってるでしょうに
笑っちゃうんです そんなもんでできっこはないんだと
ですから この 5つだけ覚えておけば
全てここにあるんです
その 5つなんですよ 邪魔なものは
これはもう一時的にでも抑えちゃうと
さっとうまくいっちゃうんですね
目指すものはね そういうことで
この五蓋という言ってる
この体に囚われること
怒り それから貪瞋睡眠
で それからこの いわゆるうわつきと後悔すること
それからこの迷い 迷い心という 5つなんですね
迷い状態 それをちょっと置いておけば
もういくらでも能力はあるんです
この迷いというのは その瞑想しても解脱するんだろうか
しないんだろうか そんなのも含まれるんですかね
その迷いって 修行に対しての疑い
そういうものもあるんでしょうか
私はね そこら辺はちょっとちょっとはっきり何か言いたくないんですけど
で 修行に対する迷いといったって
やってみなきゃ分からないということもあるでしょうしね
そうですね だから厳密にそういうことではないんですね
結局は 心にあるこの迷いという状態なんですよ
結局は  心に わかりました
例えば仏典仏典仏典では
注釈書では因果法則を疑うこと
輪廻を疑うこと 偉そうなことを書いても
私は違うと思います そんなこと一般の人は疑うしか方法ないでしょうに
輪廻なんかは これはもうお釈迦様やら仏典では書いてるんだけど
我々の実感としてはないでしょうに
だから疑ったんだからと
あんたダメやと言えないでしょうし
そういう迷いじゃない
そこはその場合も仏典であっても私がまだわかりませんとというしっかりしてる状態なんですね
そこに迷いがないんですね
だから私はこれ知っている
これは知りませんというこのしっかりした状態
それで迷いがないんです
だから個別判断の問題なんですね
まあ時々変な人々はね
こういうことを私は輪廻は認めませんと
それは何の意味もないんです
それも迷いなんです 誰が聞くんですか？その人からね
その人認めてもどうしたことないんだからね
だから自分の気持ちを喋ったんだからといって
それは真理と関係ないんですね
だからそうではなくて
あの まあいろんなところでいろんな宗教で輪廻のことは言ってるんだけど
私にはわかりませんというのが正しい答えなんです
私は知る手段から見るとそれには当てはめませんと
例えば私は知っているのは
目で見て 耳で聞いて いろいろ機械でメーターで測ってみたりして
実験してみて それで知るんですよと
私の知る手段はそれでそれには入りませんと
だから私にとってはそれはちょっと論外と
そうやって置いておくと
それははっきりしてるんですよ
そうじゃなくて あれはおかしいでしょうと
日本でよく聞こえたんだから
この仏教の専門家から専門家というよりは
この職業でやってる人々から
あれはまあお釈迦様の教えじゃないんだと
自分やってることをお釈迦様の教えでないのに
お経をやらね あんなことをやりながら
あれもお釈迦様の教えじゃないでしょうに
それでもうなんとかちょっと舐めただけで
仏教のこと 輪廻の話とか出てくると
それ自分の浅い智慧ではわからないしね
それで自分ではわからないと正直に認めないで
あれはブッダの教えじゃないんだよとか
あれはインドであったものを
お釈迦様はただ借りただけ
お釈迦様盗人ですかね
人の考え方借りる だからおかしいところはものすごいおかしいんですね
だから学者の本を見ても
これはインドのヒンドゥー教やウパニシャッドでもありましたとかだと
一つお釈迦様は概念を盗んでないんです
誰の概念も ただ言葉使っている言葉は誰のものでもないんだから
じゃあ私は日本語喋ってる喋ってるんだから
皆様から盗んだんですかね
何かを 知識でも何かも
言葉だから何も盗んだことになりませんよ
もし皆様方が考えている考え方とか
皆様方の価値観 判断やらね
それは自分でコソコソと研究して
自分のもののごとく喋るともう盗人なんですね
その時は私もこれは日本の方々から聞きましたと言ったら盗人じゃないでしょうに
だから知識の盗人はいくらでもいますからね
人の話を自分の知恵のように書くとかね
でもお釈迦様もそのようになるわけじゃないでしょうしね
だからお釈迦様は言葉使っただけ
ニルバーナもインドにあった言葉で
インド人何も知らない言葉使ったって
アッブラアッブラカダブラと
なんとかそれと同じでしょうに
それだったら何もわからないでしょうね
だから言語使っただけでね
それぐらいでも この区別判断ないということは迷いでしょう
迷いのはいいところだから
ものすごい光科学学者にならないとならないと
はっきりしています この迷いがどのようになるかということは
そこで私にそうやって仏教の職業として
いわゆる聖職者としてやっている人々もいる
なんかあれは悪いな 認めませんとかね
ブッダの教えではないと言うんだけど
私はちょっとその時意地悪をしませんだけど
もう普通の社会観 こういうところで言ったらはっきり言いますけどね
私の世界だから 私の話
喋る世界だからね で 何も言いません
だけど結局本人やってる仏教自体ブッダの教えじゃないでしょうに
そういうことだから やっぱり我々は誰かを褒めていることも応援することでもなくて
真理をするということは大事なんですね
ブッダを褒めることでも
道元があり 智者あり そんな連中を褒めることも別どったことないんです
真理を探していくことなんですね
だから これはインド文化ではこの人が大事に守る法
ダルマなんです 真実を探し求めていくんだと
この前の定義行ったところで
個人で何を守って何に命かけるかというと
真実を発見することに命をかけるんだって
人を褒めるためじゃないんです
人の好むためじゃないんですね
だから たとえ自分がすごい恩恵を受けた師であろうとも
真実はあまり助けてくれないと捨てるんです
そうやって真理のためにということは
ダルマなんですね ダルマを守ると
私がダルマを守りますよと言ったら
その人は真理を真実を探し求めていることに命をかけているということなんです
そういうことでしたけども
やっぱりちゃんとこの迷いというものはあってはならないことなんですね
ですから この迷いの場合は
今の質問に今ずっと答えているんだけど
例えばこのテキストでは注釈書では輪廻を疑う
因果法則を疑う ブッダの教えを疑う
ブッダを疑う サンガを疑うと
疑いはもうリストあるんですね
で ここの10種類あります
プッバンテーカンカティ
アバランテーカンカティ プッバアバランテーカンカティ ダンメーカンカティ ブッデーカンカティ ダンメーカンカティ サンゲーカンカティ
ジャッパチェータ パティサンパデーカンカティ
というと全部ならす まあそれぐらいですけどね
あまり専門用語言わない主義だからね
まあ一応言うのはちょっと簡単ですけどね
まあ一応リストがあるんです
注釈書に いたっても私たちも悟ってもないのに
お釈迦様は悟ったんだってのもわからないでしょうに
因果法則やら輪廻のこととかなんとか言ったっても自分ではわからないでしょうね
それはあんたに義があるんだから瞑想できっこないって
これはもう普通の迷信的な信仰型の宗教と何の変わりもないんだからね
だったら神様信じなくても同じことでしょうね
見たことも聞いたこともないんだけど
信じるんだと 同じことよ
輪廻なんかはもう全然わかりませんってこと
信じるんだと そういうことではないんですから
その場合はもう違ういう風に言った方が良かったでしょうね
例えばブッダもおそらく嘘つきではないかとかね
そんな風になっちゃうと
やっぱりもう修行できなくなっちゃうんですね
やはりブッダは偉大な人物だから
何かが知って言ってるんじゃないかなということで修行できるんですよ
だからローマ法を言うことは私は全然信じませんだけど
イエスいうことは聞くんです
なぜかというと もう正直で
別に何かもう得るために言ってるわけじゃないんですね
もう政治家で自分の権力を広げるために喋ってるんだから
もうわかるんでしょうね
だから嘘を言えると言えるし
まあそういうことで まあやっぱり偉大なる人だからね
まあうわことは言わないと
何か意味があっておっしゃってるでしょうというぐらいの理解ですか
信頼ですか それもないとダメなんですね
それぐらいは大体あるでしょう
瞑想始める場合はね ですから
そちらで迷いということは
この心にある このもうはっきりしない
もういい加減な状態 まあとにかく一般社会においたっても
普通の社会のおいたっても
この五蓋をとことんとことん勉強して研究して広げちゃうと
この能力開発の鍵はそこにあるんです
これぐらいはっきりと五つですよと言ってるんだから
六番目もないでしょうに
だから勉強しやすいんです
まあ一応あの まあ法の世界だからね
あのちょっと時間かかります
法の観察説明する場合は
今日はあの瞑想に大変大事に関わる法
真理 成長したい人にとってはどうしても気をつけなくちゃいけない真理
どうしても注意をしなくちゃいけない真理五つがありまして
そこは瞑想中でちゃんと確認しなさいと
生まれたらちょっとチェックしなさいと
それはこのヴィパッサナー瞑想の四番目の法の観察になるんですね
じゃあ今日はそこら辺で終了します
[終始背景音楽]